we defined probabilities probability and
we defined it with a fraction do you
remember what the fraction well this
looks like a big long with words on the
top and the bottom say don't remember
what the numerator denominator of this
fraction is if you want to work out the
probability of flipping your head when
you're flipping coins right well what
were your six how do you do what you put
in Toppenish okay so sample space
something to do with sample space is
really important to me does it go on the
top of the bottom let's answer that
question first someone else to help out
religious traditions start us off that
should be great
so no skinny okay number of favorable
comes let's pause on that Kim you and
see if someone else can help you out
number of favorable outcomes that's the
ones you're interested in that's like
the six or the head right but Rene
Schmitz you're something about sample
space was very helpful it's a lot sample
space though down the bottom here is
something a little slightly different to
that Jericho okay number ball total
possible outcomes and that's what the
sample space is right so you can say
number of possible outcomes or you might
recall that another way another phrase
for describing this denominator which is
I'm going to fall in the National
is the size of the sample space that's
the same idea right on a dime what is
the sample space on a dime one wanna die
one two three four five six right that's
the sample space so the size of the
sample space is how many things on it
it's six so that's why as up as we had
point out for the probability of a six
rolling a six is one out of six because
there's only a single six on there and
there are six possible things so you
remember this now I want to make this
definition a little bit finer okay what
this is is like in a perfect well in
theory so we call this probability not
just ability but theoretical probability
we're all talking about this die without
actually getting some dice out and
warming them you don't need to do any
experiments
do you remember what experiments were in
probability what's the experimental I
think fact you've got the definitions
there it's when you actually do
something right when you get to die and
you're rollin that's an experiment okay
now you don't need to do an experiment
to know that this is the probability so
what it's supposed to be okay but today
we're going to push in that a little bit
what if we actually got the dice out and
we started to movement okay now this
side III as they're heading suggests is
hold experiment
can you go back please to where you saw
a while the way you put the actual
definition of an experiment go back you
should be on the very first page of
probability what did you write down what
was your arm sentence that went along
with it experiment you're nice and
lagging you start saying it clearly okay
fantastic so we're actually gonna do
something and you guys are gonna be
rolling in a lot of dice today okay but
it's still probability so there's still
going to be a really large friction so
here's what we're gonna do instead of
another possible outcomes what we're
gonna have is the number of experiments
carried out how many times did you
actually roll the dice right did you
roll it once ten times a hundred times
and on the top what we want is number
all times you actually got the favorable
events right the number of times you got
that favorable and so for example if I
take this done any of these done I don't
know if this is a fair guy or not but I
do know it's cold where to die is not
fair we call that they call it a load of
die okay so the idea is right you've got
this the the diet and you can't see
what's on the inside so maybe what
they've done is they're put like weights
inside so that when you roll it you know
one side is more likely to go on the
bottom so that means the opposite side
is the side most likely to come up now
maybe what you want to do is find out is
this die loaded is it fair okay what
we're going to do is we're going to do
an experiment in fact we're going to do
lots and lots of experiments and find
out for instance let's just consider
suppose you are table for me suppose
what I do is I count up the number of
times I get a particular number right
and then how many rolls do I get that
number one so we already know let's
divide this up we already know that
possible numbers are one two three four
five and six
suppose we roll this thing 60 times
suppose we roll it at 60 times if this
theoretical probability was perfectly
true what would you expect to get how
many times would you expect to get a 6
if you rolled 60 times let me talk to
you it's actually 10 right that's what
you would expect let's just write down
two okay and then you keep on rolling
you keep it rolling and when you turn up
just suppose you get like 29 3 9 plus 5
is 34 plus 40 48 58 so that leaves so
just suppose this is what happened this
is suppose and you going to conclude
this is a fair die yes okay I don't want
to gamble with you okay this clearly
doesn't look there these numbers like
this number is coming up way more
frequently than anything else so I would
say the experimental probability
experimental probability of each of
these depends on what kind of
experiments you can write so for example
for the ones right
if the favorable event was once that
happened 29 times and then how many
experiments that I doing I did 60 right
so that's the experimental probability
now it's not the same as in theoretical
probability but that's kind of the whole
point I want to find out whether this is
going to be what I expect or not this is
going to be 5 out of 60 that's true back
into the fight a little bit right can I
write that as a better fraction know
what m12 Airi good six out of sixty
seven sixty what's that someone had very
good eight f-16 come on no peace out
guys wait look for a comment about 52
out of 61
10 out of 60 I can't we got this